Mitte August begann sie die gemeinsame
Militärübung der NATO-Staaten und ihrer
Verbündeten im Ostpazifik das Motto
Stärke und Präsenz zeigen gerade jetzt
angesichts Putins Ukraine Krieg und
Chinas Konflikt mit Taiwan und auch die
deutsche Luftwaffe beteiligt sich mit
250 Soldaten an dieser Mission der Plan
innerhalb von 24 Stunden 6 Euro Fighter
4 Transportmaschinen und drei Airbus
Tank Flugzeuge von Deutschland nach
Singapur zu verlegen ein Härtetest für
die deutsche Luftwaffe es gab nur leider
ein paar Pannen nach mehreren Manövern
in Australien Singapur und Südkorea
kommt jetzt das große Highlight der Tour
die große Machtdemonstration von Japan
aus Staaten die Fliegerstaffeln ihre
letzte Mission ganz dicht dran an der
Grenze zum chinesischen Luftraum und uns
jetzt aus Tokyo zugeschaltet der
Inspektor der Luftwaffe Ingo Gerhards
schönen guten Tag Herr Gerhards die
deutsche Luftwaffe war noch nie so weit
von Deutschland entfernt im Einsatz wir
haben die weiter gesehen über dem Mount
Fuji wie schwer war der Flug
also ist richtig das ist dieses erste
Mal dass wir über diese Entfernung
mit Eurofighter mit Kampfflugzeugen
irgendwo hingeflogen sind verlegt haben
wie wir das nennen und das war wirklich
da wirklich ein ein harter Flug auch für
mich bei der längste Flug meines Lebens
in einem Kampfflugzeug wir waren über
acht Stunden in der Luft und man muss
sich ja vorstellen dass wir ja dann
schon am Boden eine Stunde vorher
Anlassen um alle Systeme zu überprüfen
also man ist dann bis man aus dem
Cockpit kommt mehr als 9 Stunden an
einem steuersitz angestallt das war sehr
sehr anstrengend wir hatten hier
tropische Stimme ein tropischer Sturm
stand noch über den Philippinen und wir
haben die Ausläufer noch die haben uns
noch ja erwischt sozusagen wir mussten
dann teilweise in Wolken tanken was was
ein Riesenherausforderung
sie sagen eine riesige Herausforderung
acht Stunden in einem sehr engen Cockpit
wir haben Sie den Flug persönlich
gemeistert
also für mich persönlich war das noch
mal ein Riesenherausforderung
der so viele Stunden so hochkonstriert
zu sein wo sie das vorstellen bei der
Luftbetankung man hat dann eine
Geschwindigkeit von 800 bis 900
Stundenkilometer und muss dann mit dem
kleinen Tankstutzen in einen Korb
Treffen der vielleicht ein Durchmesser
hat von naja 40 50 cm da muss man nicht
nur die ersten ein zwei Stunden
konzentriert sein dann leben auch noch
acht Stunden und ich weiß ich habe da
meinen Soldat den Soldat mit dieser
Verlegung sehr viel abverlangt und da
war es mir auch wichtig eben selbst auch
dabei zu sein
was war das Ziel dieser Übung warum hat
die deutsche Luftwaffe überhaupt daran
teilgenommen
die Luftwaffe ist ja jetzt seit gut
vielen Wochen im indopazifischen Raum
wir haben es ja geschafft innerhalb von
24 Stunden mit August nach Asien zu
verlegen nach Singapur und dann sind wir
fast fünf Wochen eine Übung in
Australien geflogen mit vielen vielen
Nationen hier aus dem adriatischen Raum
und dann war es uns wichtig auf dem auf
dem Rückweg quasi noch mal einmal in
Singapur ein affiner dem
Transportmaschine ist auch Südkorea
gegangen und wir jetzt mit 3 € fallen an
einem Tankflugzeug nach Japan weil
gerade diese Nationen Japan Südkorea und
Singapur so wichtige Partner für uns
sind und auch wertepartner für uns
vor anderthalb Monaten hatte vor allem
auch eine Panne beim Langstreckenflug
nach Singapur für Schlagzeilen gesorgt
lief denn diesmal alles nach Plan
ich würde auch sagen dass es beim
letzten Mal alles nach Plan Ding wenn
von sechs Maschinen 5 Maschinen
innerhalb von 20 Stunden in Asien kommen
dann ist das für mich als Sofa schaffen
mehr als nach Plan
herzlichen Dank Ingo Gerhards
[Musik]